[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui parmi vous
a déjà reçu un courrier émanant de la
police ou de la gendarmerie avec une
convocation sur laquelle il était écrit
à faire vous concernant
qui parmi vous
moi ça m'est arrivé
je m'appelle Youssef Badr je suis
magistrat depuis 12 ans
et un des souvenirs les plus marquants
de mon enfance a été une convocation
commissariat de police lorsque j'étais
lycéen
je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier
ceux qui ont déjà vécu ça savent de quoi
je parle
ceux qui ont déjà été suspectés à tort
savent exactement de quoi je parle
vous savez ce sentiment étrange mais les
deux stress d'angoisse d'inquiétude et
puis le premier réflexe qui est de se
dire mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
je n'ai rien fait
on le sait
mais au fond de nous on en est pas
totalement certain
comme si quelque chose nous échappait
alors on appelle le commissariat de
police pour avoir des renseignements
mais on vous répond d'un ton sec on peut
rien vous dire Monsieur
on vous attend jeudi et ne soyez pas en
retard
je prends d'avocat je préviens mes
parents je demande l'aide d'un
professeur
lorsqu'on est étranger au milieu du
droit à celui de la justice
les questions se bousculent
on finit parfois par en perdre le
sommeil
tout autre situation
vous assistez à l'arrestation de votre
voisin ou d'une personne que vous
connaissez
vous la voyez un matin se faire emmener
par les policiers placer en garde à vue
où on vient vous dire tu es au courant
monsieur Durand le pharmacien du village
il s'est fait interpeller ce matin
il paraît que
il se dit que
qu'est-ce qu'on se dit quand on assiste
à ça sincèrement
on se dit s'il est arrêté c'est qu'il y
a forcément quelque chose la police la
justice n'arrête pas les gens sans
raison et puis vous connaissez le fameux
adage il y a pas de fumée sans feu
vous voyez ces deux sentiments ces deux
cas de figure sont humains et pourtant
ils sont ambivalents
c'est fou comme lorsque nous sommes
concernés suspectés de quelque chose
nous sommes très promptes à faire
respecter nos droits à clamer notre
innocence
mais s'agissant de celle des autres
il peut parfois nous arriver d'en tirer
des conclusions un peu rapides là où la
hauteur et la retenue devrait s'imposer
à nous tous
se retenir d'accuser l'autre ou d'avoir
un préjugement sur l'autre
ça devrait s'imposer à nous tous parce
que l'histoire judiciaire nous l'apprend
depuis des générations
ça s'appelle Mesdames et Messieurs le
respect de la présomption d'innocence
en mai 2021
j'ai eu la chance de faire partie de la
mission du groupe de travail présidé par
Madame Elizabeth Guigou ancienne
ministre de la Justice
l'objet de ce groupe de travail était
très simple se poser la question
suivante que reste-t-il aujourd'hui de
la présomption d'innocence 20 ans après
la très grande loi du 15 juin 2000 qui
l'a inscrit dans notre loi
c'est moi passer avec ses professionnels
mon profondément énormément apporté
mais ils m'ont apporté une chose avant
tout
me souvenir d'affaires judiciaire de
personnalité qui ont été accusées à tort
par le passé qui ont tout perdu
et que tout le monde a oublié
spontanément je pense à Loïc Sécher
accusé de viol incarcéré pendant de
nombreuses années
avant d'être totalement blanchi
je pense évidemment à Dominique Baudis
l'ancien maire de Toulouse accusé des
pires actes des pires assassinat violent
et j'en passe que la France entière que
nous tous avons découvert un soir au JT
de 20 heures de TF1
pendant qu'il se débat il transpire à
grosse goutte
chaque goutte qui perd sur son front est
aux yeux du grand public une preuve de
sa culpabilité
son fils Pierre qui était dans la
commission avec moi nous a dit un jour
quelque chose de très fort
il nous a dit si nous avions suivi ma
famille et moi ces accusations à l'heure
des chaînes d'information continue et
des réseaux sociaux
je ne sais pas si je serai parmi vous
aujourd'hui
et combien d'innocents combien de
personnes qui ont été accusées à tort et
qui ont tout perdu
savez-vous ce que signifie la
présomption d'innocence
d'abord je tiens à vous dire que la
présomption d'innocence ce n'est pas
l'innocence ce n'est pas ça elle n'est
pas là pour protéger des coupables
d'infraction c'est pas un totem
d'immunité qu'on vous donne
la présomption innocence est là pour
garantir quelque chose de plus grand
l'impartialité de la justice
et l'impartialité de la justice
conditionne la confiance que vous avez
dans votre justice
mais surtout la présomption innocence
bénéficie à tout le monde
le faible comme le fort
le pauvre comme le riche
et le noir comme le blanc
elle est posée à l'article 9 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen du 26 août 1789 au terme de
laquelle tout homme étant présumé
innocent jusqu'à ce qu'il ait été
déclaré coupable
toute rigueur qui ne serait pas
nécessaire pour s'assurer de sa personne
doit être sévèrement réprimée par la loi
alors la présomption innocence ça ne
signifie pas l'innocence
mais ça signifie en cas d'ouverture
d'une enquête que vous êtes présumé
d'avoir commis aucun mal tant qu'un
tribunal n'a pas décidé l'inverse
et les mots ont un sens
sa valeur constitutionnelle a été
proclamée il y a près de 40 ans c'est un
principe reconnu au niveau national
international
c'est un des piliers de la vie en
société un des principaux ciment de
l'État de droit et un principe
fondamental de la procédure pénale
française
c'est aussi un droit de la personnalité
très fort qui protège votre vie privée
votre honneur et votre réputation
la vôtre et la mienne parce qu'on est
tous susceptible un jour d'être concerné
par des accusations
en cas d'ouvertures d'une enquête elle
empêche tout simplement que vous soyez
traîné dans la boue médiatiquement et
socialement
avant d'être jugé par un tribunal et ce
quel que soit ce que vous avez fait ou
pas
et quel que soit ce dont on vous accuse
je suis sûr que vous avez déjà entendu
dans les médias le terme d'auteur
présumé
on est donc aujourd'hui présumé être
l'auteur on est plus présumé innocent
la présomption d'innocence dans la
procédure pénale française ça signifie
tout simplement que c'est au procureur
de la République de démontrer votre
culpabilité et non pas à vous d'établir
votre innocence
c'est un principe très ancien
elle apparaît au XIIe siècle et repose
au fond sur une idée très simple
nul ne peut être considéré comme
coupable tant que ça culpabilité n'a pas
été établie de façon certaine par une
preuve complète et pourquoi
parce que la justice est parfois
faillible
elle est rendue par des femmes et des
hommes qui sont faibles
l'histoire judiciaire la démontré
et je peux vous assurer qu'il est bien
plus simple de rendre un verdict
confortablement installé sur son canapé
que lorsque l'on siège dans un tribunal
lorsqu'on a la vie d'une femme ou d'un
homme entre nos mains et qu'on doit
statuer sur son sort on se souvient de
deux choses
la première c'est que le doute doit lui
profiter
et la seconde c'est qu'il ou elle est
présumé innocent
c'est au fond la fameuse traduction de
la phrase de Voltaire dans Zadig il vaut
mieux hasarder de sauver un coupable que
de condamner un innocent
alors vous allez me dire légitimement
mais ici ce principe est si fondamental
si il est reconnu nationalement
internationalement quel est le sujet
la vérité est que jamais nous n'avons
autant parlé de présomption une absence
qu'actuellement
et jamais ce principe n'a été aussi
malmené et les raisons en sont multiples
la première on assiste et ce depuis très
longtemps à une dégradation de
l'autorité de la justice notamment
d'ailleurs de la part de décideurs
publics
vous savez plus vous allez critiquer une
institution plus vous allez entendre des
critiques sur l'institution judiciaire
et plus vous allez considérer dans votre
fort intérieur que quelque part ces
critiques sont légitimes mais elles
affaiblissent considérablement la
présomption d'innocence
quand par exemple
un responsable politique comment un fait
divers qui vient de se produire et qu'il
dit face caméra je veux que la justice
soit ferme et que les décisions des
sanctions soient exemplaires
ils maltraite ce principe qu'il est
censé faire respecter tout simplement
car il s'approprie une décision de
justice en portant un jugement sur la
culpabilité d'un homme
or celle-ci se décide dans un tribunal
nulle part ailleurs
ni dans un hémicycle
ni dans un café
et encore moins dans les médias
aussi
on sait aujourd'hui que près de deux
tiers des Français sont utilisateurs des
réseaux sociaux
notre jeunesse actuelle a grandi dans
son univers numérique et sa perception
des choses on est forcément profondément
impacté
les réseaux sociaux peuvent apporter le
meilleur en favorisant l'accès à la
culture en rapprochant des gens isolés
en permettant aussi une libération de la
parole des victimes
mais les réseaux sociaux peuvent
apporter le pire c'est aussi des jungles
où tous les coups sont permis ou les
campagnes de désinformation côtoient les
accusations les plus violentes
vous savez quand on lit sur les réseaux
sociaux de la part notamment de compte
anonymes au milieu ou parfois aux
millions d'abonnés un tel est accusé de
telle fait il est forcément coupable je
le dis notamment à l'endroit de notre
jeunesse méfions-nous de ce qu'on lit
sur les réseaux sociaux méfions-nous
sa pièce totalement la perception des
choses et ça cause des dégâts
irréparables notamment pour la personne
qui est visée par ses accusations là
je voudrais vous parler d'une dernière
atteinte
cette chose est glauque elle est sale
elle est insidieuse
elle est d'autant plus meurtrière
qu'elle est impalpable
elle sent parfois elle pue et souvent
elle souille
cette chose c'est la rumeur comme disait
pierre des proches
lorsqu'on lance une rumeur sur quelqu'un
ou qu'on l'alimente
en colportant des accusations on porte
atteinte gravement à sa présomption
innocence
car on émet un avis sur sa culpabilité
alors qu'on ne dispose d'aucune
légitimité pour le faire
souvenons-nous juste qu'il revient la
justice de statuer sur la culpabilité
d'une personne lorsqu'une enquête est
ouverte et non pas à nous
alors vous allez me dire la présomption
innocence est-elle morte
je ne le crois pas
et je crois au contraire qu'il y a de
belles raisons d'espérer
ces solutions elles reposent sur vous
sur moi sur nous tous
je voudrais m'attarder sur quelques unes
d'entre elles
la première
pour moi c'est l'éducation la plus
importante la transmission aux jeunes
générations
on insistera jamais assez sur
l'importance d'enseigner le droit à nos
enfants dès l'école primaire
un enfant à qui vous avez appris ce
qu'est la présomption innocence c'est un
enfant qui s'en souviendra lorsqu'il
deviendra adulte
mettons des cours de droit au collège au
lycée on contribuera à faire de nos
enfants des adultes et des citoyens
responsables soucieux de leurs droits
mais également respectueux de ceux des
autres
et c'est très important je crois
aussi et là je m'adresse à vous plus
particulièrement
ne laissez personne vous parler de la
justice
la justice est un service public qui
vous appartient
c'est un service public qui vous
appartient mais qui est encore méconnu
du grand public
vous savez que la justice est rendue
tous les jours au nom du peuple français
en votre nom
ce soir faites un test chez vous
demandez à vos enfants vos voisins vos
proches vos parents vos grands-parents
peux-tu me citer un ou deux grands
principes de la procédure pénale
française
serais-tu me définir en deux mots
ce qu'est la présomption d'innocence
vous serez surpris de voir que les gens
ignorent les principes qui les protègent
enfin
je voudrais vous dire méfiez-vous des
évidences
la première chose contre laquelle doit
lutter une personne qui s'intéresse à un
procès ou un fait judiciaire c'est
l'évidence
l'évidence c'est un leurre un mirage
l'évidence vous empêche toute capacité
de discernement elle vous empêche de
prendre du recul elle va vous amener à
la solution la plus confortable
or comme disait Albert Camus la justice
meurt dès l'instant où elle cesse d'être
une brûlure
il m'arrive souvent
de repenser à se lancer
convoqué par la justice convoquée par la
police pardon
incapable d'expliquer à ses parents la
raison de cette convocation eux qui ne
parlait pas le français qu'il n'y aurait
toute la procédure pénale française
et je me dis aujourd'hui avec certitude
que si un adulte était venu le voir et
lui avait dit tout simplement
ne t'inquiète pas Youssef
tu es présumé innocent
donc à l'heure on se parle tu es présumé
d'avoir commis aucun mal
tu peux te rendre sereinement au
commissariat
je suis sûr qu'il se serait rendu à
cette convocation l'esprit beaucoup plus
tranquille
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]